you also were involved with the mummy
and wrote a brighter Frankenstein right
yes that's comple that was one thing I
did during the quarantine as I I came
back and finished brought Bride of
Frankenstein into a place where I kind
of always wanted it to be Universal was
very gracious to let me try again
because they geared up and shut down
famously in the sort of dark universe
fiasco darn at fiasco disappointment and
so I have a version now and they have a
version that we all really like and I
think they're they're talking to some
directors spot is it the more sort of
scaled-down Invisible Man model of it
where is it
yeah it's not the it's not the great big
you know hundred fifty million dollar
extravaganza with China movie starts it
is definitely it's not quite as
scaled-down us Invisible Man you know
but a much more reasonable doable doable
thing with I think a really cool idea
and it's all present day okay were you
were you supposed to Shepherd the dirt
universe at all would did they talk to
you about that you know I've worked with
Universal for a really long time
and they send me stuff and ask for ideas
and everybody you know and I'm happy to
consult and everybody we were all trying
to pitch in and make something out of
that and you know not all ideas work out
to their credit when I what I really
admired about Universal is they threw up
their hands and said whoa whoa hold up
this isn't working out let's stop and
just think for a year or two and I
thought that was really smart and you
know big corporations don't often do
that say you know there aren't a lot of
New Coke moments where they where they
say this was this not as we hoped we're
gonna stop and go off in this other
direction right but have you known that
we have that photo to look at for the
rest of our lives thank God of all the
actors oh sure yeah
from different places photoshopped into
one you know